foreign
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
thank you
foreign
Center to enhance the Norwegian dower if
you donate to the schools you will
ensure Allah reap the rewards thousands
of Muslims coming back to Islam and many
of those will become Dwight and invite
Islam so click the link and donate now
and share the video for extra Rewards
and to all the viewers welcome back to
the realest podcast in the Dunya the
three Muslims uh anho will join us
inshallah in a few minutes he's just
praying Salah right now but sister
Flavia how's it going
I've been good alhamdulillah sorry if
you guys can hear the dogs in the
background those are
very loud noise noise
so Rami how's your day going
alhamdulillah I'm so far so good it's
Jeremiah it's Friday alhamdulillah so
it's a very blessed day how about
yourself yeah bro good alhamdulillah
been a while since we had a revert
sister on so I'm looking very much
forward to it last time we got a sister
on a river sister we got Shadow band but
oh yeah yeah
off camera yeah yeah that's crazy you
got Shadow band for like probably like a
good three to four weeks yeah so I'm
talking posting content consistently
maybe getting like 500 views per video
it was it was crazy wow okay I want to
talk about like the
there's nothing you can talk about that
would probably get a shadow band from
everything we talked about before it's
because of where or what religion that
sister came from I'll leave it at that
oh yeah yeah yeah
but to all the viewers please smash that
like button it only takes a second helps
push the viewers uh put the video to
more viewers
um and I say we just go right into it so
what is your story with Islam
okay so a little bit of background I
guess
um
I come from a Christian family for years
who don't know
um my family is Christian they're from
Peru I was born there as well so you
know we we used to go to church you know
my family wasn't that that Christian
it's more of my grandparents and my
extended family who's more Catholic and
Protestant and stuff
so when we came to Canada you know I
would go to church and I would have um
I would have these lessons also from
Jehovah Witnesses because my father you
know he was diving into different sects
of um
of Christianity
and
um I guess I didn't really feel very
much like I belonged I guess
um I was never really taught the more
deep things about Christianity like the
Trinity I wasn't really taught that
um I learned that out on my own when I
was in high school and I went to a
Catholic High School right
um
so we had to take religion every single
year because it's a Catholic High School
and you're from Ottawa right yeah I'm
from Ottawa yeah okay so me and Rami are
near Toronto and Romney went for
Catholic school too oh no way yeah I did
it's like my area is super super white
though so a lot of the people in my high
school were just White
even to the point where when it came to
Black History Month they would gather
all the black students there was like
probably 20 20. yeah um probably 20. and
they would like those are their prizes
like you know they put those out there
but
um as I was I think it was the the 10th
grade
um we had to
once again do religion but we had the
choice to do either world religions or
um what was the other one called
or just like normal religion for
Catholicism
and I decided you know what let me do
world religions because that sounds way
more interesting than just doing
Catholic Catholicism all over again
and so as I went into it of course we
touched on different religions and stuff
but the first ones were the abrahamic
ones and I did not know that Islam was a
part of the abrahamic religions like I
knew that Judaism was but I didn't know
anything about Islam right
um my mom always told me stay away from
Arabs
never marry an Arab because they're
gonna hate you they're gonna abuse you
and I was like okay well
I don't really have to worry about that
because there's no Arabs near me so
we're at the time yeah
so
um I went into the the religion class
not knowing anything you know I learned
about the Five Pillars and the basic
stuff
and my teacher who is white taught me
you know and she was like it's not about
terrorism you know guys it's you know
it's uh the Muslims are generally good
people it's just that like one percent
that ruins it for everybody yeah and
it's not even one percent it's like
0.001 and
um so I guess on the internet
because I the internet you know
um I when I was researching
I took parts of what I was researching
and recommended it to me out of nowhere
I say it's by the grace of Allah people
told me it was a coincidence but I was
like no it's not
um so Islamic stuff started getting
recommended to me especially debates and
it God recommended to me so much that I
was just like one day I was like okay
you know what I'm gonna watch one of
these videos even it's like an hour long
because it looks here we go bro
oh
he's from Puerto Rico
do you speak Spanish
instead
alhamdulillah
let's let's speak English okay no one
else speaks Spanish
but wait when did when did you Reaper
because anho reverted about two years
ago
I did almost three years ago yeah okay
okay yeah December 2019 so yeah you can
go back to the store yeah with watching
all those like debates and stuff yeah I
I started watching debates
um of Mohammed hijab you know Speakers
Corner and stuff and I saw the
Christians and the atheists getting
absolutely wrecked and I was like wow
like subhanallah obviously I didn't say
Savannah back then I was like wow I was
in shock
so you know what I just started doing a
little bit more of my research and six
months after knowing about Islam like
the true Islam
I one day I was on my bed and I was I've
been I just had finished watching a
debate I remember
and I had my phone
right here and I just told myself you
know what
I like I believe Islam is the truth and
this was at like 3am mind you
out and out and something just told me I
was like okay I need to take my shadow
right now because I don't want to die
Cafe
and so
um at 3am I don't remember what day
Wednesday I think was like December 4th
or near the end of the month I don't
know whichever it was but around there
um I just took my shahada and uh
and I became Muslim yeah alhamdulillah
that was that was amazing it was short
like to the point but it usually starts
with a lot of debates for many people
that I've seen you know they they
stumble across Speaker's Corner
Muhammad's Resorts and it's a rabbit
hole because you're coming into it not
knowing anything about Islam you know me
myself included I was born Muslim like
Rami and my prior preconceived notions
were oh it's either Islam or science you
know it's either someone that's
intelligent or they're a Muslim so when
I see Muslims in the dawah scene that
are obliterating like you mentioned you
know these atheist scientists and the
points that we had were even stronger I
was like yo what is going on like I
don't know you could have you know
intelligent Muslims like that
subhanallah and then I you know it's a
rabbit hole so I went into looking at
you know the early you know Golden Ages
of Islam and Science and how Muslims
have literally pioneered almost like
most major scientific advancements that
we have today you know it was
mind-blowing for me it's crazy yeah
and um I I guess my story doesn't really
end there because when I say I took my
shahada
I took my shahada not like having like
full Research into it right I just had
the belief
and inside of me which stuff it Allah
like I still remember like these
thoughts coming into my brain and I just
like get kind of sick to my stomach
because I remember like the beginning of
my journey
I saw all the Muslims
um talking about
you know um Muhammad peace be upon him
and I
as a former Christian I have no idea why
I'm like I was just kind of I guess
jealous because like I was like but what
about Islam you know and I and I feel
like a lot of reverts that I've talked
to have felt the same
but I guess it's kind of like that
lingering Christianity that I had and
um I was just like but what like what
about Islam you know I don't know and um
even
like not uh talking about that like I
was really misguided at the beginning
because of the people who surrounded me
at the time
and they were very very liberal Muslims
like yeah subhanallah like I
the stuff I was told was crazy
I was told that I could pray on my
period
I was told that I could fast Ramadan
without like with water
uh what else was I told I I was told I
could pray in shorts
that's what I was told and so like
I had this very liberal idea of Islam
and I didn't
I didn't start actually practicing fully
fully until maybe I I think maybe
perhaps a year and a half in
wow really so pretty much like half of
your time being Muslim yeah exactly
so
when I took my I call my official Shadow
because it was in a mission
um when I took that one that's when I
you know had all these liberal ideas out
of my head
but the funny thing is is that I started
you know looking outside of the liberal
agenda of these like Muslims
um of those Muslims I started looking
out of it because of the fact that they
started I saw like these debates between
um liberal Muslims and like actual you
know Muslims and just like that Jubilee
video that was posted that's why I kind
of liked it so much I know I kind of got
a lot of backlash from people who are
Muslim and they were like oh we
shouldn't be having this debate like
whatever like they're just lay men and
like you know the the girl isn't she
doesn't even Muslim or whatever but I
find it to be like in my opinion
beneficial because you know
the prophet peace be upon Him mentioned
I don't know in what Hadith but I know
that it's a Hadith that
um the word of Allah Islam will never be
corrupted this is the last religion I
mean this is the one true religion it's
going to be the last you know he's the
last prophet so
it's never going to be corrupted
so when when I see videos like that I'm
just like okay you know what those are
ignorant Muslims but
it's still getting the word out about
Islam right and that's how I learned
the truth is Sam because of these
conversations that they were having so
alhamdulillah
I just want to pause it right now
um oh then we got emad on the chat he's
a gamer too
um so I'm gonna quickly add this super
chat I can't read it bro because it's in
uh Spanish Angel do you want to attempt
this
is
foreign
I'm very proud yeah I'm very proud that
you found a slam
males panel is a bless you and make you
firm on your faith I mean I mean
you got one from Harris love you big
upon your River Story I mean I mean I
was there the rights may Allah bless His
Channel and reward you okay
so you know I kind of notice this but
for most sisters that River
y'all go through like this stage of um
not really like following Islam like a
hundred hundred I think that's it's the
same for every river but more so I'm
seeing you with like a lot of sisters or
like you know they they don't have the
hijab
um they don't even really pray as much
um they still kind of were very
revealing clothing but they'll say
they're Muslim if you ask them like yeah
I'm Muslim and it's like it takes a
while before they they have that that
pivotal moment and they actually come to
like the the realest thing you know what
I'm saying yeah
I guess
I don't know I don't know
I mean in my opinion I guess it's
because
Muslim as
have a harder time adapting or like
acknowledging
that you know beauty is not everything
in this world right like subhanallah
like
a woman like a woman who is not Muslim
or who's not firm on their faith
takes a lot
from whether people find her beautiful
or not right and that I guess that's the
that's the issue with hijab and
especially maybe also you know has to do
with um the parents and everything you
know finding out if you're Muslim by
obviously wearing a hijab yeah so I feel
like that takes a really big part of it
but
for me at least when I first started
wearing hijab I would compensate it with
wearing a ton of makeup it was so bad
like
um I look at my old videos and I've
taken some down because
um
it just kind of I've
you know I'm getting those sins still
right so I just take some of those
videos down
um I know that some of those videos are
beneficial but the thing is like I I
feel weird in my stomach still having
this up
so
um it's a really big transition at least
for us Muslim as because we're supposed
to be you know wearing the proper hijab
and all our life and and all my life I
valued myself based on my beauty I was
obsessed with my beauty
and obsessed with putting on makeup
obsessed with everything like that
and even till this day I still struggle
with it
but I TR that's why like I love the
nakab because
it just it makes me more comfortable it
makes me you know not want to wear
anything because obviously if no one's
seeing anything why why would I even
bother putting it on there it's going to
ruin my nickel from the inside anyway
right it's gonna put them into uh makeup
on it
but yeah
if you don't if you don't mind me asking
what made you make that shift from like
wearing the the hijab and then like the
makeup to where now you are in the cup
a little bit
honestly at first at first um it was
it was because I got sent some from my
friend zaina
shout out to her she has a very awesome
band and stuff
um at first it was because of that and
you know I started kind of just
practicing wearing it and I told myself
I was like you know
if
honestly my actions have consequences
right
and my value as um Muslim I want it to
be the most especially when I'm looking
for a partner
and I'm not saying that I put it on for
you know to find a partner but I'm
saying that if I
am you know not portraying myself to be
the best
why would I expect the best
right and I want the best for my kids
I want the best for my future
and ultimately that's my goal right to
praise the last panadal with my kids
with my husband because I find that the
most beautiful thing ever
yeah
and I guess that's kind of somehow what
why I kind of transitioned from more of
the hijab to the face fail and it shall
like full nikob
that's really cool
I wanna I wanna rewind it a bit because
you know when you look at the Latino
Community including a lot of other
communities they're very you know they
praise Beauty and showing off and that
type of stuff so before coming into
Islam it's not too you know out there to
assume that when you looked at Islam or
not just you maybe you know majority of
people in the west they look at it as
you know oppressing women right and
maybe you know even after uh sister
accepts Islam from her own accord
they're like oh you know what she just
like internalized misogyny or something
so what was your personal Journey with
how you looked at Muslim women before
converting and then how is it now how
has it changed over the years
at first uh when I saw hijabes on the
street
honestly I wouldn't really think about
it much I just feel like oh she's she's
Muslim whatever
um
but it was really my community and the
Latino Community especially that would
tell me oh like she's too covered she's
too extreme like I don't like if you
want to be modest just like you know
wear like a skirt like the Jehovah
Witnesses do or something like you're
you're you're doing way too much
basically
and um
that's kind of how I saw Muslim as
honestly I've never I never in my
younger years I never saw in the coffee
out on the street
um or anything because I live in a
predominantly white area
and
so that was my idea of the hijab and
nakab and everything I just I saw them
as
you know on the really really extreme
end of things
and I didn't see
shorts and mini skirts as something that
was
bad
which is in my opinion a bad thing you
know my my mom she my parents would tell
me don't wear too short of things they
would still have that you know aspect of
modesty but it kind of was let go when I
turned maybe 14 15. my mom would like
just let me go out in short shorts and
crop tops and whatever she wouldn't
really care
um unless it was like too too outlandish
but even looking back at it now the
stuff that I was wearing like even
shirts and stuff it was way too tight
way to outlandish even for a woman my
age to the point where it was
attracting the wrong type of men like
when you're wearing those types of
clothes
I'm not saying that every man is going
to come like comfort you and be a bad
one but you know I'm generally speaking
if you're wearing those types of clothes
men will approach you for one thing and
one thing only
right
and a lot of sisters get mad at me when
I say that
but I feel it's it's the truth
no it is the liberal mindset is I should
be able to wear whatever I want but it's
the man's problem you know yeah
exactly but the thing is like your value
is based on a lot of your appearance
especially as a woman
right and if you're wearing those types
of stuff 99.9 of the time you're going
to be attracting the wrong type of men
the wrong type of attention
I was 14 and I was going out in that
stuff
I remember vividly this one time
um some random and this was back in Peru
I was going to go visit my old school
and I was wearing shorts and a crop top
just like I would always
and I was on my way there
and then some guy stops me and he's like
oh hi like how are you
um
where are you going and I was like oh
I'm just um on my way to visit some
friends
and he and he was like oh like can I be
your friend and I was like this is like
odd this is weird why do you want to be
my friend I just met I was like
um it was kind of awkward and he
he told he told me he asked me how old
are you and I was like I'm 14. and the
guy was like 23 and he was asking to be
my friend and I was like
I was creeped out and then he found me
on Facebook and it honestly with like
the most creepy experiences for me have
been when I was wearing you know more
revealing clothes
and it's it's scary
and that's why I guess a lot of parents
and stuff they they advise girls not to
dress that way because you're
sexualizing yourself at a very very
young age
and it's dangerous
that's crazy this is what happens in the
west yeah and I've I've noticed this
happens in like the Spanish households a
lot like um you said Peru are you
Peruvian yeah I'm Peruvian okay
mashallah see I'm Puerto Rican and um
and Puerto Rican houses it's pretty much
the same thing whereas like there'll be
some modesty in the beginning
but then like as a girl at least which
is like
I'd say maturity like a maturity for
women is like let's be honest it could
be it could be even like eight years old
for women nowadays but some women like
10 11 12 13 14. and by that point like
the parents just kind of like oh yeah
you can just try and do what you want
it's certain it really is yeah and I've
seen my little nieces they're do like
doing tick tocks and stuff and um
they're wearing like these crop tops
they're seven years old seven and
they're like a little like booty shorts
and stuff and I'm just like yo
what's going on like that's that's not
okay like um there was another instance
I remember because I used to post a lot
of inappropriate stuff when I was
younger
um and I I remember I would block my
parents from seeing that I would block
my brother I'd block my immediate family
from seeing it so that I could post in
peace
without any backlash
and
I would get a lot of messages but I
remember a couple of messages coming to
me from women themselves
and they were women who were trying to
bring girls into prostitution
and they would tell me oh like you could
you could get so much money like if you
just like do these like if you just go
on a date with this guy and stuff like I
could get you in there I started off
when I was like 16 but you're 14 but
like you know you could still start it's
like a little bit of cash on the side
I never did it because I was like I
don't want to get you know
um
I don't want to get into some trouble
with my Mom especially that's that's the
only reason why I didn't do it but these
women were telling me
oh like there's a little bit of cash on
the side like you can come do it
and I was in for it as long as like my
mom wasn't gonna catch me and that's
exactly why I didn't do it because my
mom because I was scared of my mom
this reminds me of we actually had a
sister on here a long time ago who spoke
about this y'all remember yeah sister
Milan yes
I do want to talk about you know some of
the stuff we were talking about before
the stream like you wanted to talk about
Andrew Tate's influence on you but
before that we got an important question
it's been highly requested from what I
can see in the live chat but I'll just
put one of the messages up
so para or para writes what was the
hardest thing to give up if that's not
too personal to ask
the hardest thing to give up
when people ask me this
I honestly I kind of say
makeup and like beautifying myself that
was kind of the hardest part about
everything
um and I'm still struggling with this
today so I don't I don't want to fully
say you know I have given that up
because I know that I could you know
still do better inshallah inshallah
um otherwise like everything else kind
of just came naturally to me
um I didn't like pork at the beginning
like I've never liked pork ever in my
life
um
like alcohol
never liked it either you know drugs no
none of those like I never liked those
like stuff was easy to give up
the only thing that I kind of
um had a little bit of trouble with I
guess in the beginning was
um on time for prayer
I would feel like it's not the best and
I still feel like I could do better
honestly and
um I'm planning to
every single day I try you know memorize
even more you know I try to
um especially uh uh I've seen some
I've gone in more into you know uh
arguing with liberals and stuff so I
really want to memorize those lines and
those hadiths especially just when they
come in handy I'll pull out the hijab
one
so
um I think those that was probably yeah
beautify myself as probably the hardest
to give up see speaking about liberal
Muslims I watched that Jubilee video the
one that you reacted to on Tick Tock
that is crazy there's the the women the
woman that was actually covered up in
hijab that would look more religious I
guess to like just to the eye you know
she's out here saying oh you know
alphabet gang and I'm not going to say
it to get uh off this thing it's it's
permissible in Islam it's not a sin
I was like what what is she talking
about yeah I was like that's crazy
and that's the thing right
um
I didn't like
it's not the grand majority of Muslims
that are like that
but I watched Hess I don't know if you
guys know who has sanabi is
um twitch streamer yeah I've reacted to
his reaction to that video with my
friends like just in private and we were
all just face palming at everything that
he said and his chat was
agreeing with him like they are all
liberals and he I'm not sure if he's
Muslim he says that he's Muslim but I
was seeing some stuff that was insulting
the prophet peace be upon Him insulting
Islam
stuff in Allah and he was just like
chilling watching the Jubilee video
and I used to watch hasanabi actually
back when I was a liberal and also like
a little bit now just to like see what
he was up to
I stopped watching him because he's a
major headache a major headache he's
just like blabbing on about liberalism
and how you know the Quran needs to be
interpreted uh once again just for
nowadays
or reinterpreted sorry and it's it's
crazy I I honestly can't I can't watch
him male look at him everyone's common
thing you know the top G time
before we go into it I have one last
question yeah
how did your parents react
so I haven't told my mom yet because I
haven't been in Peru because my mom is
in Peru my parents are divorced so my
mom's living in Peru with my brother
right now
um my brother's supposed to come this
year inshallah and then my Dad's here
right I live with my dad he's upstairs
actually
and um
my dad reacted
in a calm manner I have a video out
there
um I didn't know if I was gonna post it
at first because I wanted to see how his
reaction was
but
he reacted well
since he has the
he has the whole
um he was changing like sex and stuff
and his in the beginning when he was in
Canada he knows what it feels like to be
separated from his family because of his
beliefs because his mom and his family
wait you said changing sex like
s-e-c-t-s yeah
I was like what is he no no no
I'm like pause
okay okay
no but my dad has that experience with
his family as well and he didn't want to
he didn't want me to go through that
because he wanted to be a Jehovah
Witnesses a witness at first obviously
he's not now he's a deist I could bring
my dad on if you guys um would want to
talk to him as well inshallah
um I've had him you know star in one of
our
our muzzyland podcasts and my server
um but he he has
his faith is basically no faith but he
believes in God I'm gonna I don't know
if you guys know what a deist is he's
kind of like one of those and um
he doesn't believe in any of the books
he thinks that those are all man-made
and that um
the prophets were all real
but
he just doesn't believe that there is a
truth
will you hold up how can you believe the
prophets who are real when the way that
the prophets were revealed to us were
through these books yeah at least now
that when we look at the books this is
how we know of the prophets if there
were no books we would never known of
the prophets yeah exactly and I guess
he he told me and he explained to me
um that he could anyone could be a
prophet that's what he says he's like
you could be a prophet I'm just like no
no
I can't I can't be a prophet he's like
no but you you have to believe in
yourself like the prophets were just
like normal people and I was like No
it's it's not like that Dad but you know
I have I've had many many many many
debates over dinner with him over his
beliefs
um inshallah guide him
I mean I mean but yeah the rest of my
family they don't know except for my
brother and my brother was really calm
about it I just told him over the phone
hey I'm Muslim he was like oh cool okay
don't really care
I don't really care and then he knows
about my Tick Tock and he knows what I
do and stuff and he's chilling with it
yeah
the issue is going to be the rest of my
family
yeah
okay I'll make it easy for you I mean I
mean so one last Super Chat from Brother
John writes I recommend everyone read
Beauty sick how the cultural obsession
with appearance hurts girls and women
will do okay with that being said what
are your views on Abu Tate because a lot
of Muslims they are in support of him
because despite the past despite what's
been done before his conversion recently
um he's still a Muslim today and then
you have other muscle models that are
like you know what no we we can't
forgive his sins he did XYZ and we hate
him so where do you stand with that
um as a Reverb I feel for him so much
and the fact that his previous
statements a lot of controversial ones
are still public
is
I I feel for him you know it's kind of
like sad
but the thing is that if you look into
his controversial statements a lot of
them
are a to just gain attention and be
funny and then B they have a lot of
description afterwards or before they
take those clips and like you know
they put them on Tick Tock or with
YouTube or whatever like in those
compilations that are talking trash
about him and then they don't explain
why you know he said those things
um a lot of muslimites were especially
mad about the r-a-p-e one and he said
that um
you know they should take a little bit
of accountability but
you know if they if they research even
just like one Google search just to see
what his opinion was you'll see that
okay well you know
it kind of makes sense it kind of makes
sense
um
so but back when I was you know first
knowing about Tate when back when he
wasn't Muslim and everything
I made like I think two videos hating on
him
you yeah I made two videos like trashing
on his fan base and before he was Muslim
yeah before he was not okay okay
and I made videos trashing on his fan
base and on him
and then
I learned that he was Muslim
and I was like oh shoot I held my tongue
a little bit because I was like okay
I don't know if I fully believe this
because I've seen the clips and whatever
but then I went to go do my own research
and then I seen the clips myself in the
context and I was like whoa but these
aren't as bad with the explanation
you know
unless you're oh a whole entire feminist
with your you are feminist with your
heart and soul you're not going to find
those clips like too bad so
um I'm in support of Andrew Tate Mouse
panel to continue to guide him I mean do
you think that's why majority of Western
women today hate Andrew Tate
I think so
and the fact that he's Muslim now
is like
it's not shocking to them I've talked to
a few of them they're just like oh yeah
of course he's he's Muslim now he's just
a misogynist
I don't even know what the definition of
misogyny is
[Music]
like you you ask these women
simple questions and they won't know the
answer to them they don't they don't
even know why they hate him at first
right it's kind of just hate because
it's a bandwagon
yeah this kind of goes back to the point
I don't even think we made this point I
think in my head I'm making this point
but it goes back to the fact that like
we just live in the age of ignorance
and I forgot was it a Hadith or was it
something where it said that there was
going to come a time where
there was going to be a lot of like
people speaking but that the actual
people of knowledge was going to become
less and less yeah if you want to talk
about that yeah yeah that doesn't have
you yeah
yeah but we're leaving this time like we
could see it firsthand yeah you know
like we have all these like influencers
people on YouTube and look I'll be the
first one to point the finger at myself
like I'm I'm ignorant so I'm still
Jaheim I'm still learning and sometimes
I say things when I'm like oh damn like
I probably shouldn't have said this I
probably should have you know researched
a bit more and it's like I hold my
tongue a lot from saying certain things
because of this matter but then there
are others who are on the platforms and
they don't hold their tongue and they
speak more so based on um the emotion
and what they think something is but
reality and what we think aren't always
aligned you know what I'm saying
yeah absolutely absolutely and I just
want to kind of add another level of it
because people just think that there's a
like kind of there are waves in society
and all that stuff but it's a lot deeper
than that like there are people who sit
like the people at the Rand Corporation
um for those who don't know Rand is an
actual like organization that has an
agenda and they're here to fix problems
political social and all that stuff and
they have one of their Rand reports that
specifically talks about injecting what
they call moderate Muslims you know
liberal left-leaning secular uh loving
you know um Democratic Muslims into the
Muslim world and pushing these agendas
and they have praised you know certain
people who fight for secularism who
claim to be Muslim and all of this stuff
so these are not just like waves and
like oh you know these this group
believes this there are people who are
actually pushing very specific agenda so
that we can abandon our faith and I
wouldn't be surprised if you know people
actually spoke about Andrew Tate like on
a very high level and that's why he was
banned and that there is this huge
bandwagon to push him and Islam kind of
under the bus as misogynistic or anti
anti-democracy and therefore that's bad
and you know all this nonsense um
yeah and something I want to add to that
is
a lot of guys over here they
look up to Andrew because of his
masculine agenda right and you guys are
the leaders of this ummah right you guys
are the protectors you guys are the
providers
you guys the future fathers
and to have weak men is to have a weak
Society yeah and to have a weak
structure of a society
and I feel like the us or the West
is trying
to feminize our men
for the reason of control
and that's that's like I feel like
that's the main part of it because we've
had these red pill red pill guys
for the longest time
but once it came to Andrew and him
having this giant platform and him
pushing that agenda they stopped him
completely
which is concerning because they're
feeding us a bunch of pills and stuff to
feminize the men and stuff
for that control
yeah 100 and um you know like they will
let people who have been convicted or at
least widely claimed of horrendous
crimes like you know
Charles James Charles and like these
people
um and they still have platforms and
they were basically caught doing these
disgusting things and then eventually
just swept under the rug but when
someone says a few words it's like all
of a sudden this is the biggest threat
in society this is the biggest threat
that we suffer from
um no like that's completely and utterly
uh aborn to be completely honest but
again I want to take it back to the
people and the agenda uh sister I'm very
glad I made that point because what
happened the last time you had very
strong courageous Muslim men who
practice Islam almost near you know near
perfectly
a get-together in a society they
conquered Rome and they conquered Persia
and they conquered basically everywhere
up until China and they conquered
basically they were the superpower of
the world for a thousand years strong
and it was only when they injected these
agents and they injected these liberal
Muslims and they divided the ummah that
they ended up crushing them and the
further divided them that's why the
Middle East is completely divided
actually
he specifically said that when you know
promiscuity is is very prevalent in
society it will cause the men to be weak
it would weaken the people and that
would basically break apart that Society
so you're absolutely right they want to
keep us you know weak emasculated low
testosterone high estrogen but not just
that not it doesn't stop there they also
want us to be focused on ourselves and
they also want us to be distracted with
buying this and buying that and watching
this show and watching that movie and
talking about how a fun the World Cup is
and they want to distract us with all
these ludicrous small insignificant
things because as long as I'm I'm
worried about me I don't care about
fixing society as a whole so I'm very
glad you mentioned that point because
it's very important that we hit people
on the head with this again and again
until they wake up and understand yeah I
mean I mean so I have one uh you know
comment for you that I want you to
address so someone wrote Andrew Tate
made money from exploiting women how you
support that if you support an academy
in the club I don't know why they're on
the club but whatever bro
um so
from my knowledge
of him doing the whole cam business or
whatever
and um exploiting women
he stopped that stuff
and I'm guessing was for a reason
I don't know if he's talked about it yet
and stuff I'm not he mentioned
explicitly that he doesn't do that
anymore yeah like I know that he doesn't
do it anymore and I know even as a
person to have that kind of business it
brings you down it brings your soul down
you see yourself like you know
exploiting the women and their it just
burdens you right because you have a
mother
you know he has a niece he's gonna have
uh you know children in the future
inshallah if you Wills
um
so
at some point if you're a good person
you need to wake up yeah absolutely and
I want to jump in on this point because
I feel like the wording was a bit
um a bit specific because yes the word
exploiting basically just means using
for your own gain and just in a case
that word fits linguistically but it
also kind of has this underlying tone
that he forced or coerced them to but
according to the way he described it at
least these women were willing to they
wanted to they made money they were
happy doing it alhamdulillah thank God
he stopped in he's a Muslim now so we
felt so far you know be far away from
that but why are you not going after
people like you know the guy who created
only only fans that was a man he's
exploiting all these women to make money
why are you not you know yelling at him
why is he not banned why is only fans
not shut down
um but you have a problem with you know
something like like what he did which is
wrong absolutely well I'm just pointing
out a bit of hypocrisy
it's because he became Muslim and people
are having a hard time like coming to
grips with the fact that someone who did
these things became Muslim but when we
look back in time like some of the
sahaba did followers things and this
like they they some of the sahaba killed
actual Muslims but they became Muslim
themselves and Allah forgave them and
Allah forgives
everyone's sins when they become a
Muslim when they revert it's a clean
slate so I was like why are you trying
to hold this over this guy's head when
Allah has forgiven him for that wow you
know like here we are judging him but
it's like bro like we are not the ones
that judge in the end it's a lot exactly
that's such a beautiful Point spent a
lot because Mohammed a job made a very
very interesting point once in in light
of all this there are people who claim
to be Muslim who are literally
committing shirk they are doing the
worst of the worst sin and Andrew Tate's
getting getting this in there are people
who are threatening to leave Islam if he
accepts Islam and if he's accepting the
community and and you're still talking
about these things he did it's just it's
it's crazy it really shows that we've
really lost our uh priorities
unfortunately
yes puddle
um there's a lot of people commenting uh
let me see if I can pull this up
I want us to talk to your dad let's
speak to the dad call the dad can I talk
to the dad bring Dad here he has to
bring Baba well listen maybe inshallah
one day I don't want it to be something
sudden
um and that's probably enjoying his you
know Friday night
inshallah we can maybe in the future
inshallah they're probably saying that
because last week we had a YouTuber and
then we had his mom as well the
Christian Mom oh yeah that's kind of
like the opposite
yeah
that's funny yeah I've seen I've seen
that video
here is Right Flavia
it's not easy but like my question for
you is what is the best thing about
being a Muslim for a Latina
the best thing being
out of that whole sexual culture because
Latinos are very very very sexual at
least nowadays
like um
and I guess that's why a lot of guys are
into like the whole Latina thing like oh
spicy Latina like whatever else is so
so cringe to me
[Music]
um but
it's you step into that society and it's
very like a sticky sticky feeling you
feel like you're stepping into shaytan's
world
and it's like degenerate it's degenerate
and it's disgusting
yeah
so I feel like that's the best that's
the best thing I feel like there's a lot
of immense pressure too on a lot of
women today to fall into that like
groupthink mentality where it's like if
if you deep down feel like you don't
promote s work or anything like that but
you can't say it you know you gotta say
yes babe go get the bag you know support
it Queen because if you if you generally
speak your mind it's like you're gonna
be ashamed by other women
you know yeah back then if you are
immoral as a woman you'd be shamed by
The Other Women folk in your community
but today if you are kind of against the
grain of degeneracy you're going to be
shamed equally today
yeah
and you know the whole sorry go ahead I
was gonna say no hitting the point of
what you said with the uh the letting
culture it's very hard like
hypersexualized like look at the Latin
dances look at the Latin music it's all
sexualized and it's not just for women
it's also for men like as a man if you
listen to his music it programs you to
literally want to sleep with this man's
wife or this man's woman
it programs you to want to have all
these different women and so that we can
get into the whole topic of like many
hypergamous and all that no not how
pretty much my bad
polizziness they want to have multiple
women we can get inside but no I'm not
I'm not talking about that I'm saying
like the programming that's going on
within the Latin culture so for any
Latino or Latina like for them to get
out of that and then come into Islam
like that's the most beautiful thing
yeah
it's about all the modern writes Salam
sister what's your go-to Masjid and
Ottawa I'd be careful before answering
that though because you don't want to
give your location away people are weird
um well I if I were you I wouldn't even
answer that and which one did you do
shahada in if you don't mind saying
um so I did my shadow in the Ottawa
mosque
um the the main main one
honestly that's my go-to one uh when I
do have the time
you guys have a main mask
yeah we do that's how you know Otto is
small
oh it was very very boring uh in
comparison to Toronto and the GTA and
stuff but you know it's um
uh we do have a main mosque and that's
why I took my shadow and everything
um I guess that's more most main
activities
are so yeah I'm pretty basic I just go
there a lot of the time
um I haven't been there in a while
though because I do have one closer to
me but I do like the environment of the
Ottawa Mission better because it's more
diverse and stuff
um Brother Ali Maliki click he writes
being married to a Latina is like being
married to Four Women before you talk to
Dad
all right bro we'll praise
and the last one share Arabic rates what
is your opinion on the guy brother
Muhammad on Tick Tock I don't know what
he's talking about he's the one who says
it is okay to ask the dead for help
about that
um I I I've gotten this question a few
times listen may Allah bless you brother
I don't think we should talk about
people on live
um especially after it's been so outdone
on Tick Tock and for so long just put it
to rest what about the general principle
of asking the dead for help forget
brother Muhammad um no you can't do that
you cannot as far as I know completely
completely Haram you cannot make Dua or
call on anyone except for Allah
and um the only one who will be allowed
to intercede in any way is whoever Allah
gives permission to on the day of
judgment uh and that will be the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
um okay okay sounds good
um do you have any other things that you
wanted to ask us to discussed that we
were messaging before because I think we
got through most of the things on the
list for this one
um
I have a question to ask you guys if
that's okay go for it because I want to
ask some guys this
um
if you I don't know if you guys have
answered this before
um but if
you were to marry a hijabi right
or like an Agave or whatever and then
they decided to take off their hijab
you know fully
um what would be your reaction would you
divorce would you say with them
that was the goal first uh I'll go first
inshallah uh firstly may Allah you know
so you always see it was wisely wrong
sorry what
say you would tomorrow he said pick your
words wisely
um the men and the women you know from
being in such situations and being
tested in such ways I mean
I would first and foremost
um whenever someone asked for advice the
best advice is that which Allah and his
messenger gave to us and Allah tells us
in Surah Nisa I believe
when your wife is basically misbehaving
or not behaving appropriately or doing
things that you you know Gravely
disliked as someone who is supposed to
keep her on the right path and keep her
guided Allah says first and foremost
advise her kindly sit her down get her
nice gifts get her nice food have nice
you know um have a nice intimate proper
discussion with her about you know her
taking off the hijab why she did it
what's keeping her from wearing the
hijab and all that stuff and be sincere
and kind with her that's what Allah
tells us to do when he says speak you
know advisor kindly and then if she
persists and it gets to you know another
level or she just does not you know
listen and she keeps persisting in this
he says leave the bed which some
Scholars say also includes just not
talking to her and there was a time in
the life the process and I'm where kind
of all of his wives were giving him
somewhat of a hard time so he stayed
away from all of them for like three
four weeks
um he slept outside of all the homes may
Allah have uh you know send this peace
and blessing upon him
and then after if it comes to it
has different interpretations the one
that and we've talked about it
extensively yeah
one is that you take something small
that's light and you kind of you know uh
lightly hit her with it um another one
is that you it actually means to lock
like you're doing to lock you're
divorcing her or Sim you know signaling
to her that you're about to
um and as for what I would specifically
do I think I would follow that those
exact steps
um and if it got to a point where it's
like halasis isn't going to work anymore
then I I would you know eventually leave
for that but uh alhamdulillah I have not
been tested with that
yo someone will beat her down with the
Miss walk first off first of all that's
not even Islamic yeah you're you're
interesting well firstly You're missing
two steps and secondly there's no such
thing as beating down uh in Islam that's
completely Haram and I would hope that
her family would come in and kick your
butt if you did that yeah I would I
would also advise and not joke around
about things just to get yeah like a
response or laughs or something like
that it's not worth it it's not worth it
yeah my love forgot especially when
these verses are directly in the Quran
the speech of Allah so yeah
I have nothing to say I'm like Rami said
it perfectly
and so what if um
what if you can't
let's say it was your daughter instead
in the situation
what do you guys like a rebellious
daughter right
what would you guys do
I think I would um just advise her
kindly to be honest a daughter or a son
is is a little bit different obviously
um because now you don't just have you
know the guardian role you also have the
parental role and I think a big part of
that is just setting them up
um to basically be very strong in their
faith so if one day
um you know a child goes down that path
you shouldn't necessarily think what you
know what what is the one thing that
caused this you should ask yourself if
you actually really set them up you know
properly with the religion to begin with
and then you would have to start
instilling those as a foundation you
know why do why do women even wear the
hijab why it's just the same reason why
do men you know and women pray why do we
fast you know why do we abstain from
Haram it's because the one who created
us that knows everything told us to do
so and he is the most wise he is the
most knowledgeable and if we do it we we
will be rewarded and if we don't we will
be punished and once they understand why
they're doing something it makes doing
it so much better that's why you have
Muslims that become you know um they
become martyrs
you know it's not easy to be a martyr
but for Muslims it's it's a little
easier than a lot of other people
because they understand why they're
doing it so same thing with wearing
hijab I would just sit talk to her
advise her and I would know that it's
not going to be something that's like oh
okay she listened after one conversation
it will take time while a lot of the
time daughters what they need is a solid
good kind-hearted a role um sorry a male
role model in their life and sometimes
acting out like that is just kind of a
call for you know attention from you
know uh the masculine figure in their
life so you just got to be a good dad
inshallah inshallah bro someone
addressed what he said before some
crackhead right I'm not it's anyone
that's listening to this on Spotify or
apple music I'm not calling this person
some crackhead their their username
literally says that but don't think it
says anywhere that you can't make a Dua
via someone dead
well
listen
long story short if you call on anyone
or anything other than Allah
you have committed shirk you are a
kaffir there's unanimous agreement upon
every single scholar whether you call on
an idol or or on an ice cap or on a dead
person you are committing a sin
so that's a general ruling that's
applied to everything and you would need
to provide why dead people are the
exception to that rule um but don't be
misguided Allah made it very clear the
scholars are unanimous on this decision
writes fired which camera is that
quality at ten thousand or a hundred
thousand and I can't see my my contacts
are bugging
um so these are the same cameras that we
use for our in-person uh podcasts that
you guys might have seen is the Sony I
think a6000 but then we got like the
little better lenses inshallah so that's
what we use all right so what if she
took her hijab off because she's being
abused for wearing it in her area that
is white etc etc I would go out with her
I would go out with her and I'd come
ready and I'd come prepared and I'd
bring her brother and her uncles as well
and then we'd see if they still want to
touch her
man
I actually don't think we should say
much on this I think we should if you're
looking for answers on this you should
find people who are in these situations
themselves people of knowledge and
they've actually gone through it because
anything we say is going to be
theoretical since we haven't actually
been to win ourselves
um I just have one one more question for
you guys
um
when it comes to you know reverts do you
guys are you guys like a little bit
scared
of um like marrying them and stuff or do
you guys have any worries
or is it just you know
all good wait sorry what's the question
so is there like anything that kind of
scares you
if you're marrying a revert
um
it's a good question uh generally no
unless the person themselves you know
shows that I should be worried about
something
you know I wouldn't be worried just
because they're a river because if
they've been a rebirth for five years
okay so well it's not a problem that's a
good thing Allah but if they've been a
Reaver for three months then you know
he's got to look at them you gotta see
what state they're at
yeah actually I wouldn't be scared at
all and the reason I say this is because
before you make such a big decision like
marriage
you praise the color and when Allah
gives you that guidance like how can you
be scared or worried about anything
you know so like if Allah gives me
guidance
but I can't even speak for myself but
for luck is someone else guidance to
marry a sister and she's like what like
a month reverted two months like if
Allah gave the green like why would you
feel any type of way why would you have
any type of that and I get it what will
come in try to like mess with it but
like if the green light is there if you
have the guidance of Allah you can't go
wrong
personally speaking if a girl has
reverted to Islam before meeting me you
know we had some guests on the channel
that said they met a woman who was let's
say Christian where she wasn't a Muslim
yet and then he started giving a dawah
and then she became Muslim and then they
got married for me I would all of the
variables being the same obviously not
taking on-house set into consideration
I'd feel a little bit more secure in my
decision had she been a Muslim before I
met her
that way I know there's no influence of
me and there's nothing that's going to
be in the back of my mind like she
accepted a sum just because of me I'll
know like she's a Muslim because that's
what she wants to do or a Muslim because
that's what her real belief is
regardless of who she wants to marry or
anything like that
yeah that's fair enough yeah
because
um I've heard some men are kind of
afraid
to uh get married to a revert especially
in the beginning
um because they don't know if they're
gonna go back to Christianity or they're
going to go back to whatever religion
they were before
um that's that's what I've heard not
from most men I've heard it from a
couple it's like a few
but yeah that's that's why I wanted to
ask you guys this question
yeah it looks it's a I think you're
doing amazing I think if you just
continue down this path you keep getting
closer to Allah like Allah is going to
put the right person in your life you
know you don't even have to think about
this you just have to get closer to
Allah and just ask Allah ask Allah for
everything and Allah will provide you
with everything
so don't don't be worrying if this guy
is going to be thinking like oh you
should be persistent and
don't don't think about that so just
focus on the love focus on yourself and
Allah will provide everything for you
yeah that's that's kind of what I've
been trying to do I'm not even looking
for anything like that because I still
have to sort stuff out with my mom and
my family first I think that's the
that's the main thing that I need to do
and then if whatever comes to me I'll
you know I'll see
do you have anything else you want to
say
That's it man I'm I'm trying to end I'm
trying to eat these days oh we got one
last one
uh t3m I'm a Latino Reaver and I'm
seeking a river sister who knows how to
carry her religion properly Miller grant
you that I mean I mean
all right assistant anything else you
want to say before we wrap this up
um
no thank you guys so much for having me
it was a pleasure
I actually do have one last announcement
it's a very important one one of the
most important ones on this whole stream
our brothers at islamna and Norway are
creating a measured in dawa Center as
brother Muhammad hijab mentioned and out
of the beginning of the Stream
imagine you can contribute to a place
where people accept Islam learn about
Islam learn how to give dawa go out and
give dawa and those people accept Islam
as well you know the rewards could be
endless so to support the Norwegian dawa
click the link in the description and
help the brothers build the Masjid and
renovate the Masjid to expand it for the
sake of Allah he said in a Hadith he
informed us that giving in charity does
not decrease or replenish your wealth
and all good from Allah alhamdulillah so
go and donate to our brothers there
inshallah
I think that was perfect bro and guys
let us know in the comments if you want
part two stream with sister Flavia
inshallah with her dad we'll see
inshallah if it's meant to be inshallah
do you think bro and with that being
said